now we've looked at a coordinate
geometry things like midpoints and
gradients and distance formulas we've
been looking at them for a long time but
now we want to sort of just say more
than well you can work out a distance or
you can work out a midpoint but why
would you want to what might be the
value of it what can you do with that
skill that you couldn't do before
so here's a typical example of a
geometry proof that you could absolutely
do right now without any knowledge of
coordinate geometry let's just try and
spell this out for you I'll draw a
diagram to help you unpack what's going
on the first thing is it says something
about medians
what is a median we we know about
medians from statistics right you've got
the mean the median the mode in the
context of stats what is a median not a
rhetorical question have a think you
guys know what a median is you build
about them in year eight yeah seven
easier one what's it mean how do you
calculate the mean say of all the
heights of the people in this room what
would you do you would add up you'd add
up everyone's heights and then what
would you do with that you divide by in
this case eleven twelve to get the
average height of the people root maybe
170 centimeters something with that
right but that's very different to the
median how would we find out the median
height in this room what do we do well
probably action have to stand up and
move right how would you you'd probably
arrange yourself slightly differently
than this how would you arrange yourself
you'd arrange yourself in height order
right and then you'd say out of it well
let's just go with 11 right in 11 people
the sixth person along with the sixth
person will be right in the center
there'll be five people shorter than
them five people were told in them and
then the median does that make sense
so in that context a median divides
something in half in stats it's a
population in the context of a triangle
go ahead and draw a triangle if you
haven't already I'm gonna draw one that
looks like this
if you've got a triangle what do you
think a median might mean in this
context if in stats a median is about
divining a population in half what you
think a median does in a triangle I
should say what do you think it might
divide it half it divides a side in half
right now you've got three sides so that
means you'll have three medians one will
divide each side so for example draw
these with me right I'm going to put one
over yeah make that half way so I've
divided this in half that's a midpoint
but the line that joins that midpoint to
the opposite angle over there the
opposite vertex that line there that
interval I should say that's the median
okay now you can create all the rest of
the medians you've drawn a triangle I'd
advise you because this is actually a
property use your ruler actually find
out where are the other spots here so
I'm I don't have I'm drawing this
straight enough to be able to work out
where that is but I think that's pretty
close to the midpoint of that side and
going from there to the other corner yep
that'll be the median for that and then
you're going to have your last your
third and last median that goes right
down the center something like this
there we go now we know what medians are
now they divide up each of the sides
into huff so what this property is
suggesting is well sort of what I've
drawn here right but the meanings of a
triangle are concurrent what does that
mean
concurrent the toilet the diagram tells
you right
concurrent they yes alien ladder yeah
fantastic they all meet at a single
point right so we want them all to be
coinciding at that one point and we're
going to give that point the name the
centroid okay it's in the middle of the
triangle but there are lots of ways you
can describe the middle of the triangle
for instance if you do not medians but
altitudes does anyone know you don't
enjoy this does anyone know what an
altitude is an altitude how would you
describe altitude like the altitude of a
mountain or the altitude of plane what
does that mean it's it's basically the
height right you measure from directly
beneath so in a triangle like this an
altitude would be alone like that right
it's the it's the height from one point
directly below and of course you were
other altitudes in this triangle from
other points of view okay you can meet
all of those up you get another center
of the triangle but the centroid is the
one we're interested with the medians in
addition to them all being at one spot
it says this thing about them dividing
up the medians in this ratio so for
instance you don't have to draw this
part but I got a color here what this is
suggesting is have a look at Mon what
this is suggesting is that this leg here
is going to be exactly double this
length here does that make sense see how
it's a ratio of two to one
yeah I might even write that down there
so I'm going to pause for a moment I
want you to think how would you go about
proving such a property with all of the
knowledge that you you have you actually
know enough here I'm not gonna clue you
in a little bit I'm gonna give you three
or four minutes work with the person
next to you think what could you do here
you don't actually have to do the proof
I just want you to think about how much
you even start on the proof if this is
what we want to show they all come
inside here and that you're gonna get
this ratio two to one I guess you'd also
have to
- one and two - one how much you do it I
actually want you to think for a few
minutes and then I'm gonna show you the
way that I did it okay off you go so you
come up with you've got an idea
call me over okay can I show you now
this is just kind of a prelude so I
don't want to pay too much of our time
in this I actually want to properly
prove it with this okay but let me just
say this right now this is not a nice
proof if you just use all the knowledge
that you currently have remember when I
said ratios did anyone think of what
kind of knowledge you have apart from
college geometry that has to do with
ratios is you've got a couple of
different directions you'd go in any
thoughts on ratios you've got triangles
think trigonometry should be like one of
the first places you go because that's
all about the ratios of sides in there
one of the problems that you have with
that it's not insoluble but one of the
problems is trig ratios we tend to think
of them in terms of what kind of
triangles right-angled triangles and
surely there are right angle triangle in
here but I don't have any at the moment
it's just some random triangle so that
would mean I'd have to go through like
sine rule cosine rule it's gonna be a
bit achy yeah what other kind of
knowledge of triangles do you have that
has to do with ratios things you've had
to prove before that give you things in
proportion just in the way I said ratio
come on think similar triangles similar
triangles give you sides in particular
proportions right now when you have a
look at this guy
this is the way this is the quickest way
I could do it with the knowledge that
you have before quartered methods this
was the proof I came up with I don't
need to jot it down I can send it to you
if you want or I'll just leave it up on
the screen if you want to have a look at
it but it's um it's awful okay let me
point out how awful it is number one you
just look at its length okay why is it
so long it's because there's not just
one there are two similar triangle
proofs involved it's not only got two
similar triangle proofs it's one of
those ones haven't got my diagram where
you have to think of one of those
constructions that's like who would even
think to do it like you know you see a
solution you're like who dreamed that up
right I didn't see that to begin with it
works though you could follow every
single line of this and you'd be like
yeah yeah yeah makes sense could you
come up with it probably not but but it
can be done well okay the whole point of
me showing this to you is to say well
now that you know that actually we can
do this by corner geometry there are
ways that are
immensely easier yes you could do it
other ways but watch how nicely this
falls out if we actually think about
this through a coordinate geometry lens
okay so underneath where you've drawn
your diagram right for me proof now
we're going to tackle this with the
knowledge that we do have that we have
developed in quarter geometry okay